thank you very much
please - I love you - I love you too I
loved oh you guys I am Larry one more um
so how was your day - oh as many of you
probably heard this is our final week of
the nightly show I know four or four
shows left and I just want to thank
Comedy Central first of all for this
rare opportunity and it really is a rare
thank you come on and also the staff of
this show we have an amazing staff you
guys for giving it their all this past
20 months I want to thank all of them
here and especially I want to thank all
of our fans let me just say you guys
have been unbelievable we have the best
fans in late-night I'm saying it right
now
um it really is true people come up and
they never they never say hey nice show
they always say thank you though it's
such a cool thing and hearing from you
guys has really been incredible
even you at little more blow six six six
I mean you brought such a unique voice
to the dialogue I appreciate that now
when we started the show we wanted to
have a conversation of some very tough
subjects and we've had a lot of fun
doing just that I mean really our show
was at its best when the news was at its
worst and I'm just so proud that we were
able to take on real issues and I don't
know hopefully save something powerful
while making people laugh and on some
very very dark days my only regret is
that we won't be around to cover this
truly insane election season although on
the plus side on the plus side I must
say our show going off the air has to
only mean one thing
racism is solved we did it we did it
back back in fact I think we have a
photo from Ferguson that was taken
earlier today
yeah you're welcome America welcome but
black and white aren't the only issues
out there right now
orange seems to be the biggest problem
facing America so let's check in and see
what's happening with the unblocking in
that thing's gonna haunt me for a long
okay now last week I made a few jokes at
the expense of Trump's folks Goblin
Katrina Pierson um I don't want to give
the impression I was picking on her just
because she's working for Trump I would
never do that
Goblin lives matter you guys okay
they matter Hey but then she has to go
and say this
remember we weren't even in Afghanistan
by this time Barack Obama went into
Afghanistan creating another problem no
new new new new Obama did not go into
Afghanistan now you're just being stupid
for stupid sake okay I don't understand
what is wrong with you people
perhaps you're not familiar with all the
disasters from the Bush administration
there was a terrorist attack we got into
two wars vice president shot is friend
for Christ's sakes there is a horrible
hurricane which thanks to you is no
longer the first thing that comes up
when you google the words Katrina in
total show okay but
but sake maybe you were gone fast
and you didn't mean to say that let me
give you the benefit of the doubt that
was Obama's war yes mm-hmm
but look at the confident way she's
fused that book was Obama's war yes now
earlier today she admitted she got this
wrong after the entire world told her
she was wrong but here's what really
gets me guys
she's the spokesperson for a man seeking
the highest office in the land all she
had to do was be alive for the last 16
years right to have known she was wrong
and keep in mind as a goblin she may
have been alive for centuries I'm saying
this is possible also genetic and this
Trump surrogates not only spew these
lies like with confidence sometimes the
boat coming out of their mouth surprises
even them so to be clear mr. Trump has
no financial relationships with any
Russian oligarchs but that's what he
said and that's what I said that's virus
leader to power positions
the book is coming out of his mouth so
fast you almost want to hold his head
back right go ahead man get it out take
your time ah but someone who doesn't
seem to mind the taste of book in their
mouth is the is the bovine Duncan Asura
himself President Obama he is the
founder of Isis he's the founder of Isis
okay he's the founder he founded Isis
I would say the co-founder would be
crooked Hillary Clinton please make up
your own joke there the Trump soon
followed that bad crazy statement by
doing something very presidential
sending a bat crazy tweet all right
ratings challenged at CNN reports so
seriously that I call President Obama
and Clinton the founder of Isis and MVP
they don't get sarcasm look that's not
sarcasm sarcasm is when you tell your
friend with the ugly shirt hey nice
shirt not sure why you would do that to
your friend he's just trying to get back
in the dating scene after his divorce
but regardless sarcasm is a pretty lame
excuse but at least Trump kind of
admitted he was wrong right obviously of
being sarcastic then then but not that
sarcastic to be honest with you
to be honest you're never honest with us
the end of your sentence stated the
complete opposite of the beginning of
your sentence do you have any idea how
confused the middle of your sentence in
oh I got to keep it 100 about this
election donald trump has stopped being
funny he stopped being outrageous he
stopped being politically incorrect he's
just downright dangerous anything and
the word and the worst of it is he's
just a liar okay and i don't want to
hear Kevin King King Jane Eyre - okay
that is a false equivalency let me tell
you something
Hillary Clinton is a very smart and
capable politician who many people don't
trust because she spends too much time
lowering her words so she doesn't lose
votes instead of telling us what she
actually thinks all right Donald Trump
is a psychopathic narcissus who not only
has the hands of an infant he has the
mind of one
what you say you say and I apologize to
all infants so stop comparing the two
Donald Trump is an existential threat to
America and if you love America like me
you have to hope that Hillary Clinton
wins every single electoral vote this
November let me just say let me make
this clear it's not so much that I'm
with her it's that I'm with her we'll be
right back
you